Speaker 1: OK, so I'm going to criticize
something Joe Rogan said on his show about
coronavirus vaccines recently, but because of the
emails I've been getting, I first want to say a
couple of things. First of all, I haven't been
avoiding criticizing Joe Rogan because I've been
on his show or because of some loyalty to him. I'm
not doing this segment in secret, hoping Joe Rogan
never sees it. I am not it regularly in touch with
Joe. We've been in touch a couple of times since
I was last on everything I'm going to say here.
I would say to Joe if I were back on his show,
this is a disagreement about the vaccine, we would
be able to talk together about it and everything
would be fine. It's not some weaponized hot take
or call-out. I haven't avoided criticisms of Joe
Rogan more than I have of anyone else. I just
don't watch much stuff. When people send me
something from his show or others, I look at it.
The Dan Crenshaw example from a few weeks ago is
an example. So let's just jump right in. Joe Rogan
made statements on his show about vaccines that I
believe are dangerous in what they are encouraging
people to do and the risk that they discount if
they follow. Joe Rogan's advice is significant
and it has to be addressed. So let's look at the
first clip and we'll jump right into this.
Speaker 4: And people say, do you think
it's safe to get vaccinated? And I've said,
yeah, I think for the most part, it's safe
to get vaccinated. I do. I do. But if you're
like twenty one years old and you say to me,
should I get vaccinated, I go, No, no. Are you
healthy? Are you a healthy person? Like, look,
don't do anything stupid, but you should take
care of yourself. You should if you're if you're a
healthy person and you're exercising all the time
when you're young and you're eating well and like,
I don't think you need to worry about this. Yeah.
Speaker 5: I tend to agree with you.
Speaker 1: This is not about you worrying about
getting covid if you were twenty one and you
don't want the vaccine. When we say the vaccines
are ninety two to ninety five percent effective,
that means ninety two to ninety five percent.
In some people they are less effective. Just
thought process is only about the twenty one
year old evaluating their own risk. But what
about the risk of others? I don't have to give
you a hypothetical. My dad has a type of blood
cancer called multiple myeloma. They recently did
a study of vaccinated multiple myeloma patients in
them. The vaccine is 50 percent effective. It's
one study, but they took a group of vaccinated
multiple myeloma patients. Two weeks after
their second doses, they check their antibodies.
Half of them did not develop antibodies. So my
dad got vaccinated. I got vaccinated. My seventeen
year old sister vaccinated. Right. We all did it.
But at some point things will go back to normal.
You won't need masks in grocery stores or at the
car mechanic or wherever else. So masks are done.
The twenty one year olds don't get vaccinated
because they follow Joe Rogan's advice. My dad
goes to the grocery store and some twenty one year
old who didn't want to get vaccinated spreads it
to my dad. It's not some hypothetical of Oh,
I need a mask on the bike path. You all know
I'm not big on the outdoor masks. I never thought
we needed them except in rare big crowds. This is
the vaccine cuts down your ability to spread the
virus by ninety percent. It reduces the amount of
virus that is in the systems of vaccinated people.
My dad has a 50 percent shot of being immune with
the vaccine. He did everything he can. He got
vaccinated, but he goes to the grocery store or
the DMV and it's filled with twenty one year olds
that her Joe Rogan say if you're twenty one and
healthy, you don't need to be vaccinated. Well,
it's not about your level of risk necessarily.
It is about you as a twenty one year old, as a non
vaccinated person could be infected and incubating
with a large viral load because you're not
vaccinated and then you spread it to other people.
The vaccinated twenty one year old has a reduced
ability of spread. Ninety percent reduced. That
protects my dad and the five to eight percent
of people who get vaccinated but do not develop
immunity. It is not just about the twenty one
year old. Now, if you don't care about others,
if you're the twenty one year old and all you
care about is yourself, ok, but it's dangerous
to say that that's the only calculation. If you
understand the importance of considering other
people living in societies, the principle at
play is if you aren't likely to die yourself,
maybe don't get vaccinated. That's what Joe Rogan
is saying. Doesn't work. Most people individually
are not likely to die from the virus. If we
went by that, we would never get anywhere
close to herd immunity. Let's continue.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I tend to agree with you,
but there's a lot of jobs that will tell you you
need to have this. Well, that's what's starting to
happen. People are worried about them doing it for
their children. And we talked about this earlier
that you might have to have your your children
vaccinated. And, you know, I can tell you as
someone who is both both my children got
the the virus. It was nothing. I mean,
I hate to say that if someone's children died
from this. I'm very sorry that that happened.
I'm not I'm not in any way diminishing that.
But I'm saying the personal expense. That my
children had with covid was nothing.
Speaker 1: So, again, same issue
about his kids versus his kids
spreading it, the longer this goes,
the more the spread is shifting to children. So
it's not just about the kids, it's about other
people that the kids might spread it to people
who might be vaccinated, but could be in the
five to eight percent who don't develop immunity.
Or if you're immunocompromised, it might be more
like 40 or 50 percent don't develop immunity. And
then also this thing about vaccine requirements,
you know, schools have required vaccines for
decades. That's just an aside. We've dealt
with that before. I don't feel the need
to go into to that too far. But there's
nothing new or unique about vaccination
requirements for schools. Let's keep going.
Speaker 4: One of the kids had a headache. The
other one didn't feel good for a couple of days,
like maybe, I mean, not feel good. Like I'm like,
no, no big deal, no coughing. No, no, no achy,
no. Like in agony. There was
none of that. It was very mild.
It was it was akin to them getting a cold. Yeah.
Speaker 5: And you can have this thing where it's
like you were saying this virtue signaling
and this kind of like theatrical display
of I get the vaccine, what a good person I am.
I care about everyone. But you're like, look,
my daughter is a lot younger than your kids, but
I'm like, yeah, I'm not injecting my daughter with
something to fucking vertue signal. Like, I'm
not doing that right. If there's something that
she's of no risk statistically has no risk from,
I'm sorry, I'm not taking any experiment on her.
And that's that's my attitude.
Speaker 4: But it's amazing
that that's controversial. Yeah.
Speaker 1: The reason that it's controversial
is that it's based on nonsense and ignorance. I
am right there with the fact that there is some
virtue signaling and theatrics around covid
guidelines. I have said the masks outdoors
when you were walking on the bike path or
passing someone on the sidewalk, I have seen no
evidence that it was ever necessary to wear a
mask in that situation. I'm not interested in
virtue signaling. I am not one of these lockdown
lovers that people on the right like to say shut
everything down forever. No. When two weeks ago
vaccinated Joe Biden and vaccinated Kamala Harris.
We're on a stage together, outdoors, alone with
each other. And they both wore masks while the
other spoke. I said there is no reason for that.
Maybe you do it for theater so that other people
see it and maybe they behave more safely. There
was no reason for that. But vaccinating people
not at risk themselves to protect others is not
virtue signaling. It's not controversial. It's
just caring about humans. Then this other guy
also says an experimental drug, the vaccines.
Listen, if you don't trust Maryna vaccines for
some reason, there's no reason not to. But what
I'm saying is, if you don't trust them are any
vaccines, there are so-called regular vaccines
available for the virus like the Johnson and
Johnson vaccine. Oh, but David, the blood clots
one in one point two million. All women age
18 to 48, their kids are not in that group.
OK, if you don't want an experimental MRN,
a vaccine, then you get the JMJ There's an
answer to that as well. Let's watch one more clip.
Speaker 4: That even saying that I'm not going to
inject my child with the vaccine is controversial.
Yeah, that's crazy because again, we are not
talking about even the flu that we just found out
killed twenty two thousand people last year. We're
not talking about that. Right. We're talking about
something that is not statistically dangerous for
children, but yet people still want you to get
your child vaccinated, which is crazy to me. But
you should be vaccinated if you are vulnerable.
Speaker 1: I actually don't know why the focus is
on they want you to get your child vaccinated
because the vaccines aren't even approved for kids
yet. Now, at some point after rigorous testing
that's ongoing, it might be soon the vaccine or
multiple vaccines might get approved for younger
kids. It's not even approved right now. So this is
genuinely disheartening to see. I have no issue
with Rogen personally. I'm glad to talk to him
any time if he wants to have me back on. I'm
not saying anything I wouldn't say to Joe if
I spoke to him. I'd say, Joe, I'm worried
about this for the reasons I just outlined.
I don't assume that he's doing this because he's
a bad person, because I've seen no evidence he's
a bad person, I think he's just mistaken. And it's
it's not sensible commentary. And because so many
people consider what Joe Rogan says to be gospel,
I am worried that lots of the 20 something year
olds in Rogan's audience will hear this and say,
yep, that's why I'm not going to get the vaccine.
I'm a healthy twenty one year old, just like Joe
Rogan said. And unfortunately, that is a recipe
for never getting out of this in a serious way.
If you care about other people, this is not good
advice mathematically, medically, statistically.
And I'm glad to talk to Joe about it any time.